count me down from 100 guys welcome to
punch-drunk sports we're back and guess
who's back say it say it I'm bad Sam
Tripoli's back we're here with fight
nany and Johnny he was also back Johnny
was home for nine months except Ari
who's just doing street drugs apparently
literally street drugs drugs he finds
yeah if you try this on and you don't
die then I'll do it too that's so funny
you know how they have food tasters like
Trump had a food taster that died right
is that true yeah that's what the see
this the Secret Service guy had like he
was supposed to taste his food magic
that's your job
you Rochambeau well they used to have
that all the time like back in like the
days of like you know like the feudal
days like kings and queens there was a
guy with it because everyone's two
always trying to poison the king there
was a guy that had to eat it's a food
first and if you didn't die then the
king would eat it what if they what if
like famous people had drug testers and
like you had the tested drugs first and
before you do it and they're like okay
smoke this okay it's PCP and I'm jerking
off punch like I want to do that [ __ ]
yeah I could see I mean alright if
anybody would have that to be re and I
feel like that'd be like one of us well
the thing is though the guy doesn't know
he's doing that you know saying hey I
got something for you yes well no you
would hire a drug a drug now you know
then you have to pay him just don't tell
him just me yeah just pay him with free
drugs yeah drug addicts don't want much
other than drugs he's such a drug addict
he just will do it for the food drugs
and and the hang I could die but you
know it's free drugs and I get to and I
get to hang out with Ari ah dude it's
good to be back in the saddle I missed
everybody I do think for now on July
will be a month off just like every year
you need a little breather sports are
slow
it's just baseball and it's good just to
you know go away and kind of miss it for
a while what's wrong with just baseball
chip baseball's great I love baseball i
watch the dodgers every night but it's
like it's a two-hour sports podcast we
can't talk baseball for two
Wow I'm gonna start tangy no can what is
that you guys guys guys that's been
enough baseball talk we've talked about
not enough baseball already during this
episode can we please I'm gonna start
taking a football season and a
basketball season of yeah I love you
took your shirt off [ __ ] so what are we
talking about here by the way no no I
heard your baby died is that you don't
say that you and I said it right before
the show and you say yeah and you talk
about it during the show
no I bring it up and you're like stop
her baby didn't die she's a competent
mother stop where's your child right now
if it died Howard what would be the most
like probably I don't want to talk about
getting shaken to death what about
getting shaken to death it's so cute it
is being choked with a baby ghee would
be her most likely there's no way Oh
like a ghee joke out become baby death
podcast monsters I just suggested and
maybe your child's no longer among the
living so so you're raising her as a
particular gender I said what's going on
here are you raising her as a gender you
picked her you made her yeah Victor
genbank I mean she was born
we're gonna go grow so unprogressive
call yourself my hair getting back to
where a once you go vote for Trump again
you dumb [ __ ] we've seen a speaking of
Ohio trash has anyone seen Tony hands
cliffs new Corvette which is such a
white-trash marriage and if it wasn't
for those orange stripe said that I
would be like you know what it's a cool
black Corvette but then he has these
orange no white trash it is a black
Scott has like weird swipe some weird
spot I'm happy for Tony hey me too I
think I know a car which is are gonna go
run and tell them I'm happy for him I
hope he'll is a side of you grew up and
why
trash when you get poor with all the
nice cars out there yeah like the new
caddies the new you get a Corvette like
what do you go cruise high schools to
seriously you know I was saying the
other day babe
jump in don't worry about it I got a
quarter
hey you guys need a ride to the prom
it's got a new Whitesnake's
I got room for one of the two of you my
favorite things that all these young
comics and this will be one the last
times I refer to Tony as for the young
comics he keeps going I'm one of the
up-and-coming young you're 34 that's a I
don't know coming in yeah yeah yeah
you're here okay you are you and that's
from a super old okay but I've been
described as one of the best
up-and-coming young comics I go by who
me who do you think you can ask I say
that I love him though I'm happy that
he's doing well I mean that shows doing
great it's Hillary but wake um you see
you got a Corvette who still drives a
Corvette who was the inside leopard did
they are they remaking Cannonball Run I
want to show up in an ambulance that's
what I'll do you know you want bring
back cool you put in the new Fast and
Furious that's the only way Corvettes
are gonna be back to what they were cool
for about six months when that damn
Jackie Chan movie came out with Chris
Tucker where he drove that stingray I'll
hold that all black and yellow mmm I
just figured that's what that movement
know I know we're talking those 69
stingrays were cool for like six months
oh that's a different car that's a
different car yeah that's a Corvette
you're talking like a new Corvette yeah
yeah it's like no right yeah I mean
unless it's really it's one of those
that's like when white trash wins a
lottery and you go first thing I'm
getting brand okay your brand-new
Corvette man yeah black car orange
stripes I am down on the vision board
you know for years I call it the
Lockhart
okay that's what like a young comic gets
a gig and like they assume it's right
there it's just cash forever
yeah and they go buy the most ridiculous
Kapil I did that to know
Freddie lockhart got on Frank Caliendo
show that lasts about three episodes
because it's really hard to do
impersonations of people when you're fat
the understand I'm Salem Freddie's
impressions what Kelly and I started
stealing Freddie's impressions how do
you steal an impression it's quite easy
to do actually d are you stealing what
the you're doing in the impression do
you understand I'm saying like yeah like
but there's like for example like I had
to learn before Richards had to learn
but once I start doing to learn then
Richard saw how to do to learn you Nate
I mean oh but if I'm the host of the
show right and you've got a good let's
say [ __ ] Stephen a Smith which I got
and then I start doing I hear you doing
it in the writers room yeah and then I
want to do Steven Naismith now yeah cuz
you showed me how to do it he was doing
that oh so he'd be like I Barack Obama
and then he's like I want to do fat face
rock Obama exactly right exactly right
exactly hand oh the show should be
called +30 pop thirty pounds it was
every impression plus thirty pounds hey
where are you gonna be Oh me well I will
be just like all of us at the all things
comedy festival October 25th of 28 so I
need to come up to them about that
everybody not be there wait what where
would you be it's a long story I got to
talk to you guys after all right well I
will be at that and hopefully Sam will
be at that too and then in the following
week in November I will be at the Orange
County comedy festival that's there's a
festival in Orange County week after
that yay Oh awesome
I'll talk to you about that after cuz
you'll be in it too I got to talk to you
and I will be doing a historic thing and
during that there's going to be a crazy
podcast one-off podcast only that I will
be doing with boom-shaka-laka and damn
by like at the same time oh [ __ ] the
meeting of the minds we are working
we've worked things out yeah a little
bit I'll be at the store this week I'm
at punchline ah no way I'm at the face
punch line on April Fool's Gold
hey fool's gold so I didn't even know
and then big guys and thanks to
everybody for the support I'm having
Tommy John home surgery on my dad on the
19th so I'm finally getting the elbow in
my dick fixed I'm so happy for them
I'm so happy that what about you sir ah
this week I know I am at this Friday
night I am at the Ventura Harbor comedy
club with Mike Catherwood from k-rock
Mike Tully from the JCL show and Lisa at
from the Church of what's happening now
we are doing a nine o'clock show there
then the following week jim Florentine
myself
Kate Quigley and Carlisle forester we'll
be doing the comedy palace and say eight
o'clock show it's San Diego it's an 8
o'clock show that's gonna be a great
[ __ ] time and then the following
night I am going to be at I'm gonna be
at the dojo doing the show again you can
get tickets on Eventbrite if you want to
go to San Diego show it's gonna be I got
all new material dude so come out San
Diego to that one and I think we should
all go out to Vegas for the fights
I would love to it the only data that is
25th yeah I I'm down for that I might I
might get a Airbnb and just get a house
the baby bring them now as you want to
be a good mom bring whatever well have
Pollyanna wash your lawn you have Jeff
isn't that movie that's some Disney
movie Pollyanna watches the baby and
together that's a cartoon right baby
gets in trouble looking for drugs on the
street Polly Ann's got a saver by
fighting off trans hookers technically
you could leave her and like the pack
and play what's gonna happen she might
get hungry
see there's great parenting if you are a
parent please do not listen to her if
you need good parenting advice please
hit up Jeff Dennis on Twitter I'm real
quick a lot of tinfoil hat way to give
your days they show you next Tuesday
there's a little hard
together and it's just getting super
competitive but I enjoy the same lineups
now are starting to happen I feel so bad
hitting these people up yeah I feel
awful
yeah oh god they must hate getting paid
and performing in front of a sold-out
manor every comic Kate's getting that
call hey can I pay you to do a sold-out
main room ah man you buggin me again no
but what you're talking about okay
because I have to put a certain amount
of [ __ ] names in there these are
people play theaters all the time yeah
they're playing one on Tuesday it's
called the main room of the Comedy Store
and it's each 500 okay that's a theater
I got that point Jason Tebow you know
you've gotten good since I've been gone
you've been practicing I've been
practicing on your [ __ ] debating
skills yeah everyone's like Sam Tripoli
quit forever which means two weeks two
episodes you missed two episodes no I
miss a month almost skank Fester's in
the middle so it's kind of complicated
yeah so you guys all got paid some more
cash somebody told me cash what what
okay
why'd everybody quiet because we don't
know you're talking I was like thank you
you did I looked at both of them like I
know next question this is because Sam
got a ton of cash cash I got was from
you yeah I pay off it really was um so
much stuff to get into sports watch
Johnny anything you want to talk about
first let's get into 2 to 7 right at the
Newseum the worst devastated I got a
call to go do that but I had a show I
had to call to go do what go go to the
fights Oh
who had to hook up my friend stapes we
have to start going and watch these
major fights going on in town there's so
many things going like they don't come
here that much you know it's like that I
mean dude I love
I mean boxing happened Garcia happened
there were seats available and then the
UFC was there man it's great dude all
three of the one two three two co-main
event and in Cub Swanson
all three of the people that I wanted to
win was same I was so sad and Cubs
wantin
almost the biggest surprise actually my
last followers of me on Twitter you guys
like I'm not big on Twitter cups the guy
comes once and fight I don't even know
his name he has 1000 followers and was
like this is so sad he got beat by
someone that has 1000 followers on
Twitter I think everybody know that
should there's a real correlation
between you but the final one knows who
he is
dude here's the thing about fighting you
believe that Greg Hardy is fighting
every bouncer from the comedy store in
the last 10 years dude I just can't take
tits on my fighters these come from a
guy with tits I just can't take unless
it's Miesha Tate yes I mean like unless
it's a chick a guys I can't take like I
dad bods are fine we'll take some dad
bods
but dude when you got cups homeboy I
can't take it very rarely are we on the
same page where we always want the same
fighters like I was so sad when my deal
you and I yeah I mean like the whole
card oh okay yeah usually we pretty much
my team I lost I go Cody's gonna lose
now because they've already lost I was
like walking around the apartment so
upset of the three Cody was the one I
wanted Cody to win but Cody was on wrong
you know I could see him losing I did
not see Mighty Mouse was it and I
actually don't think he lost you don't I
don't
but those takedowns they take it so they
give so many points for but I feel like
and tell me what you guys think about
this let's say let's say well you watch
the fight let's he gets taken down but
Mighty Mouse was so quick and creative
of how he would get out of a takedown
that's my deal you don't get any points
with that you don't get any point every
time we got taken down he took zero
damage sort of for takedowns that he had
or whatever it was got weighed so much
more than everything else that he did
yeah well they gotta find a way I think
to fix that because I agree it's not
like he stayed down you don't get you
don't get points in scoring for a good
sprawl yeah good takedown defense yeah
or if you if you take me down and I
immediately you know cage walk and we're
back up and nothing happen from that
takedown
well I just don't want to watch like
tackle that's you know if they're just
tackling each other for points that
weight class is just weird because
nobody's blown knocking out anybody in
that weight class
it has been four years whoo [ __ ] my
hoody knock down knock down that job his
den des or whatever I think so yeah
Diddy Johnny um I can find that now
Johnny I liked Johnny it's like I'm back
and I don't care he was checking his
attention his cow in North Carolina
taxing those players from North Carolina
be still getting those sneakers I like
this bomb Bob here we go you watch the
fighter yeah I watched him afterwards
who do you think won and in your honest
opinion you watch the fight the Mighty
Mouse fight do you think that was just a
no-brainer pinion did you got a beat the
champ to beat the other that's my
opinion and do you think he convinced I
know biggie nice out but I'm just like
Mighty Mouse is just oh man he's just
big I keep getting told constantly
getting told that he's the
pound-for-pound best that's all I hear
all the time and you don't think a teen
fight win streak 11 title defenses in a
row nobody's ever come close to either
of those things in any way clasped for
me that way class is like and I'm gonna
get a lot of [ __ ] for this women's MMA I
love I personally think it's like wow
they're so fast and fun to watch I love
it no one else has that speed I just
think that's not deep enough yet yeah
there's not enough guys in that weight
class to be like this guy's the best
it's like for me it has always been
level of competition is more as
important as your streak like a guy who
beats like a deep division maybe as a
couple losses is way more but it's way
better of a fighter to me then someone
who is undefeated in a completely
[ __ ] thin weight class and that's
what we've seen it that way I hear what
you're saying but I disagree it a little
bit because I don't think that this
division is what it was for Ronda Rousey
when there was six female fighters
who are named either made me the finally
okay go through Johnny I know that
you're texting people right now no Betsy
is cow
if you just go mighty my bucket dear
Liza dare Eliza let's see his division
how deep is this division Joe Dotson is
like fighting like [ __ ] right history
or is yeah yeah just like you know can
we get everybody can we rank right this
is everybody's beat yeah always cleaned
out how many Hall of Famers are on that
bat list probably only him I'm gonna
scroll through this can you guys see it
yeah the guy did just beat him cuz he's
fought John Dodson twice and Joseph
Benavidez twice right those are the best
one and hoot oh yeah i'ma call him twice
back-to-back gave him another shot
well he Dominic Leone I think if I
dominate crews twice as well no no he
did he did I don't think Cruz went down
that far you're correct sir yeah also a
new mom all three of those fighters have
new babies and I was just can't handle
you know their daddies needed to win
yeah yeah because he's a good parent I
was hurt all day every day water him to
be home for three hours on Tuesdays I
guess what he's doing it how do you even
know your baby yeah how do you know who
has it
what's that called sorry 2009-2011 but I
see what you're saying um yeah dude I
you know it's like you know who's a
pound for pound great fighter George st.
Pierre obviously Daniel Cormier going up
fighting bigger guys this guy's been
singing you're trying to just get these
get this record and I respect that but
it's like you can't sit here and tell me
that this guy is that one the
pound-for-pound
asked when he won't go up a class and
fight anybody but then against Anderson
Silva didn't do it either but I don't
know man
I just I uh it's a thin division isn't
the whole idea of pound for pound the
that no matter what size you are you're
still better than bigger guys yeah like
pound for pound you know even though you
have very good pounds if they all
weighed the same that if you put them
all in a [ __ ] cage and they all have
the exact same weight same size same way
this person would be these people yep
and I don't have to see you literally
want them to put on the pounds just see
that yeah that's what Sam wasn't never
like me fine tape which I challenged him
to a fight right now that'd be like the
crocodile honey look at this now we got
a little 125 hours I love how he became
Irish really quick yeah I'm very excited
for finally we got khabib and Conor I'm
not even gonna watch it that's how much
I hate Conor put your baby in a dumpster
and go out and get hammered [ __ ]
terrible do you mean I just woke a let's
before we get into that can we just talk
about the the fight and TJ and how the
the problem with this fight was and the
reason I don't think it was as big it's
because Cody just couldn't talk [ __ ]
right and like him talking [ __ ] and
hyping fights now I think Cody got
pushed to the front line because anyone
II don't wanna beat Dana because he's a
good-looking guy that's a good-looking
guy you guys sell [ __ ] tickets girls
would go gaga
that's a good-looking [ __ ] right there
right and it was like 12 and oh right
out the gate with like 11 knockouts and
that's exactly what Dana wanted like a
[ __ ]
yeah and you know the truth is is like
Cody's like what
five six years younger than TJ so it's
like he still has a room to grow a lot
of room to grow man he's too emotional
you know it with the gloves on in the
Octagon he's too emotional like the
minute he thought he kept him he came in
too hot and was in any disguise yeah
again no patience no patience yeah it
really was a cookie cutter of the first
fight they looked identical I love that
women now fight like like 1920 swimmers
right it's the same so now so who does
calling out golf brain I mean a dull
Shaw no one cares about that yeah you're
Mighty Mouse was gonna do that and then
he just stole the same thunder yeah cuz
that people care about that more cuz he
cleaned that division like Sam said I
don't know who to versus diligent means
nothing me and Dylan Shawn is even like
came back the day after the fight at a
press conference was like I don't think
he really deserves that and he doesn't
he needs a fight Cruz why everyone said
this means he's the greatest
bantamweight of all time when what
happened to Cruz's record like why well
TJ better than that just because he beat
Cody twice who said that who said that
your baby no Rogen said it when he
interviewed him and then Daniel Cormier
decided to and I was like what oh good I
love him to death but sometimes there's
I'll fight him right now you'll fight
Rogan right I won't Rogan and Tate at
the same Rogen's fists are as big as
your head I know when we were talking to
him the other night was like his hands
are ginormous because fingers like
regular microphone for him this is just
like his whole this would be like baby
Mike yeah this would look like when Bob
Hope hold no what's his face from the
crisis anyone but sometimes Rogan will
get excited with some of the Dominic
you'd have to be dominant Cruz and then
go on a nice run well there's another
example of I don't get well I tell Emma
cheetah arrow right you're like okay
next fight gets knocked out yeah
exactly I don't get why why somebody
like Mighty Mouse has done so much clean
that division I'll own the vision only
person holding that belt since the
division started why doesn't he get a
[ __ ] rematch
why wouldn't he not are going to give
him but he's already challenging and he
wants to move up another weight class
and do all that because he thinks that's
a superfight and they'll make more money
if you fight baby
so weird to be that size and be the
exact same height as your new baby right
probably like the baby could carry dad
at the same time yes
what so I think what was the other Oh
Connor versus a little bit but just to
that same point it's the same thing to
me with Cormier and there's all this
goddamn hype about [ __ ] uh what's the
UFC guy Brock Lesnar it's like why would
you not give the steep steep and who's
the most title defenses in heavyweight
history why wouldn't he get a rematch
would you see that sweet juicy word
Daniel Cormier he goes if if I can't
make it I'll give him a rematch no no
and he goes if if Demetri Martin Demetri
Martin right tell us one more bad joke
where Mighty Mouse doesn't get a it's
something about Mighty Mouse yeah and
it's like hilarious he said it yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I think people are
warming up to him for a long time nobody
liked DC because he was bad at [ __ ]
talking and everybody was no pressure on
John I hated DC is because John Jones
was the the prince here it is dude Sears
here's the quote right here right and
based on reading okay only you take your
glasses off to read this if Dimitri
Johnson doesn't get a rematch there's no
hope for any of us in the entire Johnson
okay come on because this me you're
reading it and you can't how do I say
his first name if wasn't Dmitri Dmitri
is Johnson doesn't get a rematch there
is no hope for
any of us in the entire world because
that means nothing you could ever do
will Warren getting an immediate rematch
title and by the way you know who's who
huh
put the eyeballs on that or no steep a
put hmm weird right yeah right that's a
weird thing for him to say yeah
considering he's gonna take the cash
come on dude may your Braves burn in
hell I mean how did you put your
prescription and notice that not only
could you not see but it got darker in
the room root bro rude rude rude rude
let me put your glasses on down in
Margaritaville Johnny take take your dog
and get out of here Connor verses can be
uh every khabib is opening up as a
favorite but let me tell you how close
you got look it up let's go to bat DSi
bet the aside for all your bet needs
that's a great place to put some bets
down on this thing put some bets that'll
make that cheddar use a code punch 25
and I'll give you 25 bucks to bet with
and I tell you what now is the time to
bet NFL is right around the corner I'm
very excited as everybody knows we're
excited about that baseball is heating
up we'll talk about that next week
yeah you're right but um used 25 you use
a good punch 25 and I get your 25 free
bucks to gamble with from a good friend
to bet dsi dot-com get the app and we're
trying to still working on with our good
friends of bet DSi because they are also
sponsors of our good friends at Legion
of skanks I wonder how they got that
sponsorship so do i and that fights in
three weeks and we are gonna see a good
friend Ryan and you'll possibly beat the
tar what's your take on that I think
Ryan O'Neal beats
Liu Jitsu ji
gomez that's what I think I think it's
gonna be interesting to see we were
talking about him being like a minus 175
maybe minus 150 close but not that you
know who's one'll being a bit of a
favorite I mean I think I think it's
gonna be one'll well it's gonna be
interesting because I think it's gonna
open up with a fury yeah and if nobody
gets knocked out it's just gonna get
slowed down until like people getting
tired when we were at skank fest a lot
of people that wasn't one of the bigger
questions that I got the two questions I
got the amount with three questions I
got the most one is Sam really gone
forever
- are you sure fight nannies baby isn't
black and then the third one that I got
she looks like Milan oh she does and
then the third question I got was how
could he think is gonna win this fight
and I go the difference between the two
is Gomez feels disrespected Gomez might
be angry and emotional and he wants to
punch and may possibly even hurt Ryan
O'Neal he's excited to be analyzed he
filled everybody saying that he can't
win and every lot of [ __ ] talking going
back and forth right the difference is
Ryan O'Neal doesn't give a [ __ ] he's
just happy to be in a fight like
O'Neal's been fired he's been in a
zillion fights Gomez has never really
been in one and he's mad and wants to
like defend his honor O'Neal's like I'll
fight anybody really a fight sure I
thought you know so that's feel like
Ryan right now is in like because he's
held 40 now now mind you warty I think
this will be his peak physical that
he'll be at and after this it just goes
downhill I want ya maintain this I want
to see both because I still I'm not
convinced [ __ ] 1920 swimmers he wasn't
gonna take a shirt off well yeah well I
think that it always is yeah I would
respect if he did acid mine well that's
the thing the other the other reason I
would make him a little bit of a
favorite is like when we're in Brooklyn
we would do a podcast and O'Neal is like
all right I got to go I'm gonna go train
I gotta go train and I'm got a mile and
a half on
and no matter bike chugging like whiskey
out of a bottle no chaser on acid though
and mushrooms he was doing everything
yeah yeah I think there's a little bit
of a focus thing going on to that I
would make me ask you towards Ryan
behind every great festival there's a
great woman who runs it the girls have
it like keep Ted sure you mean East
Coast Dana yeah yeah
East Coast Dana and people would do it
yeah yeah you have to get the ladies
going cuz everybody else is on acid yeah
I didn't do a stir when I was there I
wish I did I would done a sit-in [ __ ]
Paulie I love the people now just
hobbyist rooms twelve years I just love
it it's like normal yeah they're like
hey dude here's some shroom them what
okay thank you I give it to my brother I
don't like I don't know what to do yeah
I would trust you give it to the baby
let the baby just you got like one drink
from like punky and you'd be like it's
like kill me know what I do at the
Comedy Store
I gotta give him the wink of an eye
gonna take care of Dana that means heavy
pours yeah that's the only way they calm
her down
because she'll grind me the whole
[ __ ] night what my dad okay take care
of mama take care of mama they put her
down she does I just like I'm like
nobody's ever gonna talk to me here
again at this [ __ ] place they have
that the crew for us like it's like
hormones Jen's nice and it's like they
know who knows us and we how to deal
with that like Connor versus could be
thoughts these are the odds man okay
let's hear it these are Bethea size odds
bet dsi for all your bed needs go to bed
t si.com use the promo code punch 25 get
$25 back in cash big bucks no whammies
McGregor isn't a modest underdog at plus
one five five okay that's it's almost
even the favorite is at minus 185 could
be
thoughts guys I mean you obviously hate
him I really won't watch any press
leading up to it I will not watch them
it'll be fantastic I think he's like I
don't mind him entertaining that's I
just get more and more angry yeah it
could be wins it's gonna be all over the
internet and then I'll watch the fight I
don't need to hear the like beginning hi
pups you're really not gonna watch the
goddamn fight what is it October 8th
some more than I hate him October 6 rock
well that's closer than I thought that's
wasted I was like holy [ __ ] think that
this mom eight weeks if you reconning
McGregor would you be fighting in UFC
again this year yeah it's - I would I
would have taken that boxing thing into
the ground dude because he was making
today I wouldn't really May weather
already like where he's listen dude cuz
what what 'national a loser
when all that stuff goes away all the
other stuff I think if you lose I
disagree dude I think Conor McGregor's
at a place where he puts on such a show
like win or lose it doesn't matter I
mean like his ass man when I get yelled
at by everybody where I said he's gonna
he's actually gonna get bigger after the
Nate Diaz loss and it was like your
folks stupid and he just kept getting
bigger man it's that wins or losses it's
like battles man you gotta have bet if
he goes out there and gets wiped with
[ __ ] off could be then it's not your
link this will be a battle I think it
will be dude there's you know what
toughest fight he's ever had in his life
yeah but you know what dude honest to
god but that doesn't mean it's gonna be
a bad no no he's great at getting you to
[ __ ] play to your weakness because he
makes you almost calls you out like you
know
oh he's never gonna strike with me he's
a [ __ ] [ __ ]
he won't [ __ ] like trying to strike
with La Quinta yeah cost him a lot and
it's gonna cost him if he [ __ ] fights
here if he does that I mean you should
just get Conor and put him down but
there's something about Conor
that gets you the [ __ ] fight the
wrong way in their life I mean dude
but he's gonna be all over this [ __ ]
Russian dude interviews interviews
interviews it's a deep deep deep waters
man it's deep waters and that's why I
think Connor has a psychological edge
yeah I mean like dude let's a
psychological edge absolutely so like
without question he has that it right so
khabib oh could be fought right but
remember before the key people sound
like two years I just kept getting
injured and interest can be you seem
like a guy that had is affected at all
by psychology though not too much but he
seems like a guy that might not be able
to make weight that could no he'll do
this though I think no I think it is
problems we've dealt with that doesn't
know if somebody's in your face talking
mad [ __ ] to you and like you're not used
to that that [ __ ] with your head when
you when you're used to staring at some
bait and you see them just kind of like
break down and that doesn't happen that
gets in your [ __ ] head
look at everybody look at look at
[ __ ] Jose Aldo who was this guy one
for a decade that is a Triassic example
of where Connor got in somebody's head
yeah
he did get in Aldo's had big time right
so it's like he made him fight this
fight rush in and get knocked the [ __ ]
out in two seconds
it's like he's it's like wargames I've
finished I'll do though I mean he was
done after that for that he needed that
and you could see in his face how
emotionally he was with that win day he
was like I needed this or I might have
been done that fight it's like you
bombed two times in a row which is rare
from all of us because you know we're
doing it so long but somehow you bombed
two times in a row and you're like and
with all your new [ __ ] or something like
man if I bomb again I might I might be
done I might just maybe I should just be
a writer or something then when you kill
you're like I needed that man it is
[ __ ] weird it's like that it's I mean
he would need it Aldo needed that win
you could see emotionally on his face I
mean it might have even been crying
after that win oh yeah do you know where
the what room in LA is like the mindfuck
room the small room at the improv
there's ah somebody got raped or
murdered in that room and they haunt it
the lab and it's like you come out like
what crowds
I'll be here and you walk in it's like
[ __ ] a roomful of like [ __ ]
first-generation Iranian immigrants and
you're like who's gonna enjoy this
[ __ ] show you know what else give me
like that a little bit the dojo yeah
Jackie you guys can go in there and it's
packed and you're like [ __ ] man but then
you go in there and there's like six
people yeah I'd say great you're like
[ __ ]
Stephen Glickman to show not one person
showed up it's like it's a weird room I
mean it really is ah there's no rhyme or
reason
it's a gorgeous room it's not a room
that it's a great room but we're doing
no reason to without any help
it's [ __ ] rough but I'm enjoying it
so I'm gonna take right now Connor on
that fight it almost might be a little
too early for me to and by the way I
could either say this I don't know it
sounds like I'm making an excuse I'm not
I'll take Connor right now as well I bet
your baby takes Connor too just so
pissed like how did this get on our
Yamini chefs baby but I could easily
change that in the next and this is one
of those fights work please God please
please the gods of bet dsi calm don't
let anybody get injured or anything
happen to postpone this cuz everybody
has wanted this fight for two years and
it's finally signed and it's finally
it's one of those fights it might not
happen again - if it gets postponed like
a couple of times I don't let you see
yet don't let don't let this fight
become the Manny Pacquiao Mayweather of
MMA don't keep moving this thing around
for two years and then it just never
happens so I hope to god by the by the
gods of bet dsi dot-com use a cup 125
that nothing bad happens with this no
I'm equally as excited for one of my
good friends and you know I'm sorry if I
seem a little tired I was hanging out
with my good friend last night till
almost 2:00 a.m. Nate Diaz also fighting
[ __ ] your brother are you gonna bring
this up she's got her brother God so
that's even better friends that issue
yeah I mean but no yeah I'm not friends
you know her baby's daddy I'm friends
with his brother and he's fighting in
September and who to fight like boy did
you see how he said the next day he
wasn't fighting because he was
disrespected because the u.s. he doesn't
respect him well the funniest thing is
the funny thing was he also said hey I
ain't gonna be on that fight dawg I
didn't gonna be on that car dog was like
you're not to you know no no no he said
this I didn't talk to him anything about
that fight I say congrats on getting
another fight but we didn't really talk
you know he's going to talk about yeah
what did you talk well the cool thing
was he the coolest part was right when I
first saw him he goes dog your hairs
long and I'm like I know I swear to God
I felt like a [ __ ] 12 year old girl
that was hanging out with [ __ ] new
kids on the block and they remembered
you
and then Chappelle was there and he was
with like a entourage of fighters so I
got him all like a lot I got a free
powers with fighters no no no
Diaz was and he wanted to see Chappelle
so I got him all like a booth in the oh
and they just stand there watch the pail
do you like two and a half hours I think
Chappelle's still on stage right now
yeah okay very interesting cuz back in
the day nobody cared that Chappelle was
doing those long sets but lately people
like dude get the [ __ ] off stage I want
to go well people like dreaded they're
like oh oh no one day which is he likes
to pop in on the money and by the way if
anybody's in Los Angeles right now I can
almost guarantee you Chappelle will be
there tonight to almost guarantee
because I was talking to his driver if
they're not there where you give them
$1,000 to everybody I was up I will suck
your [ __ ] with $1,000 ting people are
I'll line my throat with thousand
dollars and I'll suck your [ __ ] and when
I'm done all the money will be wrapped
around your dick in you now do you think
people are hoping for or against
Chappelle being there do they want to
see Chappelle do they really want that
[ __ ] thousand dollar [ __ ] I'm
willing to bet they want the thousands I
call a million paper cuts on your dick
which one you want I'm willing to bet
they go they're going paper cuts I'd
much rather take $1,000 then
imagine em and all those paper cuts on
your dick and you put on your underwear
you like huh thousand dollars ah you
can't get a lap dance she's grimy huh
you know what's cool that Chapelle does
his driver is like super cool that guy's
awesome and so I just talked to him he's
always happy to see me and he stands in
the back of the room stands in the back
in a room I know dude he's your great
guy but he always stands in the back of
the room and all he does is talk sit and
anybody that's recording anything he
grabs the door guy goes that guy right
there so all he does is like hawk people
recording Dave [ __ ] yeah I get it man I
I did a bit I was working on on Rogan
once back when I got to do Rogan and I I
did it at a show with him and nobody
laughed because I get hearing a hug
they're like oh they'd already heard it
on the [ __ ] podcast and it was a
great bit so if you're going it well it
was the babe it was [ __ ] how did you
know why [ __ ]
you know I saw murder the other day
Duncan he's got like I knew 10 or 12
minutes the murder so [ __ ] funny
so funny and by the way big
congratulations to our good friend
friend of the show Duncan Trussell
having a baby in January his nobody
pulls out anymore you know why cuz the
comedy boom I was thinking about this
you think the comedy isn't having a huge
boom right now first of all every comic
is having a baby
yeah and second of all the parking lot
at the Comedy Store and Saturday looks
like a Porsche dealership it was like
this horse is talking about six Porsches
remember back in the day lovely those
people aren't Brogan's [ __ ] Tolliver
McCallum yeah but remember back in a day
when it was a news story it used to be
Jeff Scott's car a rowboat Tommy's piece
of [ __ ] tiny piece of [ __ ] a rowboat and
like they'd be working on a float for
the Gay Pride that was awesome enough
[ __ ] chariot I'd have a chariot and
now I remember when those eight does I
used to carry you
yeah that's a rickshaw those are the
good days when I had a rickshaw now it
looks like an about him I don't haven't
seen one of those at all luxury car
dealership or you came yeah any comedy
stays to come Sammy the rickshaw
you should get Bobby Lee's dad to
[ __ ] pull his brother
they are a little closer to the ground
it's like yeah that's why Asians are
great with rickshaw it's their little
legs
it's also why so many drown when there's
like typhoons you know because they're
just okay dude
we'd like to issue an apology I think
there's too soon how when was the last
time there was a giant type five six
years ago the memories are still fresh
god Johnny what happened to you did
somebody diddle you while you were gone
why no you know did your County now with
Johnny right now what's going on last
night very late very late when did you
get it Johnny hasn't slept guys we know
we know that makes him hate Asians they
could be Asians but they could be aliens
he just needs a nap he needs a nap
Johnny you need a nap and a Baba he
needs his Papa John's II need a Baba now
well uh why don't we just I'll let you
go with one of the best parents at the
table
Sammy girl help them Oh suck out my
nipples jet breath but it comes out like
[ __ ] it comes out like yogurt I'm like
be wide nipple it looks like silly
string yeah that's do you if you don't
if you don't do it for a while do you
get like pressure build-up where you can
like get some distance
yeah and how far can you ever know I
have a pump in the car and I actually
left it in my rental car yesterday and I
had to call the dealership today and I
have to go home and get up what an
embarrassing walkest and when they leave
hey man we get we have here we have your
breasts yeah we have your JD pumper no
that have a worse one that happened to
me I left my flashlight in a rickshaw
that I rented I'll pick that up here's
my porno scenario laughter Tom
forgets titty pumper goes to place guys
are like Alden from the like [ __ ]
for the Nerds need a hand
well you want this back move it what
prove it puppy
by the time I get my pump I'm gonna need
to pump them so I might do that what
genre was that would you say that is the
reality no I called this morning in the
lake so are you having like a build up
like a pressure like hours and dresses
huh
Jeff if I'm not back in an hour do not
text me um speaking of dressing up the
woman I was at Sunday night dude I don't
know why that night there was just a
bunch of wild chicks at the Comedy Store
like it was Wild Wings Sunday night yeah
it was just like all girls dressed like
Chris D'Elia was there but he wasn't and
they were just there with wild in their
eyes drinking that's cool they're not
yet sometimes he's just like you're like
something's in the air yeah it's
definitely young person's place you know
I'm saying like if you were 26 you could
be slamming right now I think I told the
story on on on the show before but I was
talking to a girl who asked me how old I
was and I told her and she goes my dad's
that age and I was like bye Felicia bye
Felicia
that was my cue I'm just like okay well
so you and you be safe tonight young
lady yeah I mean like back in the day
now I just want to give you a real edge
now I don't know I do what's the point
what's the point
because eventually they're good round to
the nearest like 10 as I think when
you're right down to the nearest so you
round down to 20 I'm a 30 how old do you
tell people you tell me a real age yeah
I do now but I'm saying if I was on
Grindr do you put your real name your
0:40 um hey do you end up this I do joke
about you know your old is when your
fake age is old
yeah like how old you are 40 ah your own
yeah because I can't fake 30 anymore
I can fake 40 but I can't fake 30 a lot
of people do that right what a lot of
comics do that yeah like Stephen is easy
still 38 I mean like he's been 38 for a
good 10 years I think now boom Shakalaka
was 39 when I met him and he's 39 20
years later I was like you were 39
before I was 39 and then you were 39
after hours it's a white seaman yeah
regiment of white seamen that's oh he
talks about all the time he says it
keeps him young I've heard him talk good
skin so white guys are like how you bird
like you didn't you active research for
71 or 72 wrinkles I would do a Facebook
like that everyone's that'd be great if
there was actually a place where like
you can just get melt you see the Sun I
would've never guessed because I chose
an old you've kept like 55 oh no what J
for his age yeah Isis and a song said
dombarris was 55 no yeah 55 no way how
old is dombarris 45 oh no no he's gotta
be in his 60s sixties you really do you
think Dawn's in the sixties well I know
this he's been same age as Madonna
because this math too and then he's like
he came out in the 80s he's like that
was like 40 years ago how old's Madonna
they they graduated high school together
the same high school done bears and
Madonna with high school Oh 59 oh my god
don't tell dude it's like this though
it's like William William Shatner look
at this guy now there's a thing you can
do you can get fatter as you age and
stay young forever watch look how old
you know and his face he's way 87 years
old
William Shatner's 87 look at his face
what dude the guys are the pros life he
just gets fatter that's his move he
looks good though 490 yeah Wow
90 years old he gets Olli bang 60 right
now right
you'd be like banging six his hair's
fake but that's that's nobody likes a
guy he's really Witter
yeah like doodies and the Tories he
looks such like an alcoholic right there
hurt look at that one that's like I
building collection ninety years old if
you if you get that old and you're still
a rocking it you deserves
you can drink into whatever do amazing
dude there's what's the chances of any
of us making eighty-seven Johnny could I
mean I probably don't have eighty seven
days left oh yeah you're a live to be a
thousand yeah yeah yeah you're gonna
live during these zombie apocalypse you
like you be I just want to get my brain
uploaded to a computer go all the way
like and especially like once you get
divorced and your kid won't talk to you
anymore buddy because you baby's daddy
is such a good parent yeah you live a
long time my mom should live forever
she's never drank never did drugs never
smoked she's gonna be a thousand years
old
how's her health now what did she buy
sorry yes she's great yeah she's 70
she's wonderful
I love her see that those are words your
baby will never say on Spotify you
really have the cutest baby back you
have the cutest baby baby you okay
Kovalev he got knocked off yeah he got
knocked down three times did you watch
the fight Sammy I did yeah I mean I
watch it afterwards I didn't do such
combat sports is a cruel [ __ ] and you
lose you lose a [ __ ] sliver of your
speed he's awesome released between life
dad he got old after that second Ward
fight well he's a lot maybe agree of his
last five I believe well one of the Lord
[ __ ] so he's really only lost two of
his last five in my opinion but
everybody's saying he's done he used to
have a great chin now and now he doesn't
yeah that's I think he's going to become
into Chuck Liddell yeah like
heavyweights he's not quite there but
yeah that's totally where I can see it
going yeah Saturday yeah yeah
let's talk about now this is a guy
that's good friends with me and Sam and
everybody because that right in front of
a soccer game yeah and the funny thing
about him is all these Mexicans kept
coming up to him at a clipper game and
right after the first ward fight and
they kept coming up to him and asked him
to take photos with him and he's sitting
right in front of us and he had a
entourage of people with him probably
his whole [ __ ] camp oh and sam says
to me who is this guy
and I didn't want to say his name out
loud so I just I don't look him up
online that new kovalev well I looked
him up online and I just held up that's
who it is and you're like oh okay
you know when you go down what happened
Bob look it back I mean you go down like
that that's that's really well you got
that weird like your arm is back like a
[ __ ] deer just shot I mean I he just
went like the championship yeah one of
yeah yeah yeah I mean he's up there he's
not too old but he's like bidness [ __ ]
forever but not forever but for a long
time started I think he started late
he's 35 yeah so yeah he's yeah he's
getting there yeah it's a cruel cruel
[ __ ] world dude and then again I mean
it's kind of like like Chuck Liddell
like once your chin goes when you're
known as a striker and you're a knockout
artist once you start getting knocked
out it's if you're not a finesse fighter
yeah like a mayweather a guy who just
doesn't get touched yeah if you're a if
you're a slob shiburin ski
that's someone's [ __ ] name that is
true what if wherever that guys from
that's like Joe Smith they're looking
for yes it's lon Gabreski like which one
one another come on buddy be more
specific
[Laughter]
okay Hampton ship ran skis can we talk
about that like Showtime I think is just
starting to destroy HBO and boxing this
was an HBO fight yeah but it's like show
times put on great no vice
well Paulie Malignaggi
I think bringing him over helps a lot
because he's they didn't for the longest
time I didn't like their commentary you
know and I think polygon Ozzy they're
just putting on more fight you don't see
a lot HBO fights like Showtime just
going Halle used to be the gold standard
yeah now it might not be yeah how about
this you want to hear some crazy LeBron
James has a show on HBO and Showtime
he's on them both like one of the shows
that's like being a blood same self rip
how do you do that do what anybody could
the same show or two different no one is
a barbershop show and the other one is
just dumb [ __ ] show they doing called
shut up and dribble which is like based
on this Laura Ingraham who's a [ __ ] L
complaining yeah and then of course
Donald Trump and like what people like I
just see HP I just like dude they should
just do a show on ESPN called fat chicks
finger-blasting to LeBron James cuz all
they're just like all the Browns just
taking on [ __ ] Donald Trump and he's
not putting off with a little bronze
like Jeff it's just like they just DJing
their vaginas they're [ __ ] cow the
whole [ __ ] time by the way what okay
it's dude they all play to each other
tribe is the king of all the idiots
LeBron loves this [ __ ] dude he loves it
because you know what LeBron has been a
[ __ ] elite since he was 14 years old
since he showed they use a [ __ ]
grown-ass man he was a [ __ ]
next-level basketball player he had
everything [ __ ] set for him so he has
to have these moments were like these
[ __ ] kids in the inner but a lot of
people that were smelling everything set
and he didn't handle it well there's a
lot of people that know my handle he
needs these moments to make him
relatable to the [ __ ] kids in the
inner city so now he's fight the other
kids in the inner city watching HBO no
my point is that these giant fights he
has would like Laura and Donald Trump
plays to his base he [ __ ] loves it
just like they [ __ ] love it because
it plays their bait and they're like
yeah man tell those [ __ ] pro so
spoiled brat pro athlete what did you
shut the [ __ ] up in the past month in
baseball three guys had pitched great
games you have been like a media
before their the word of their almost
no-hitter went around they're getting
reamed on Twitter for [ __ ] they did in
high school on Twitter yeah and what
super just rap lyrics right it was Sean
Newcombe for the brave the Trey Turner
and you know what Twitter's become it's
not only it's the tattletale of this
it's become the kid in the back of
school that's like and like you're in
the back of the class and like you're
like hey man [ __ ] this test mrs. Johnson
he just said the f-word that's what
Twitter's become all of a sudden but you
can't do anything good you have to like
okay wait a minute before I pitch this
no-hitter
do I need to delete any tweet from high
school yeah that's they just they're
like who's doing that though [ __ ] let's
go ahead and no here let's go look and
see if you said I want to get famous or
do something to get like famous and then
I'm just gonna like at my press
conference I'm gonna go like I accept
this movie role but before we shoot it
I'm gonna kill myself because you're all
gonna find out that I've said some crazy
things that I didn't mean on my podcast
six years ago oh yeah dude I mean you
can't even run for public office here
they really no one on this show can run
for anything we can run from the cops
that's the only running we'll be doing
you know so funny as you could tell that
skank the Lygia skanks have started to
get big you know because like I love
those they're going after like the
creeks in the cave yeah all their their
podcasts there and it's just these white
beta [ __ ] are like I can't take it
you're saying meanie [ __ ] and you see
the guide the thing that Luce posted
where the guy was supposed to come on
the podcast they were I would say she's
like [ __ ] you I'm coming I'm in jazz at
the park with my friends like dude you
just went a little next-level [ __ ]
not only are you calling out people for
jokes but now you're a jazz in the park
like there's they dude if they drop the
bomb on anybody a jazz in the park
I would not shed one [ __ ] tear go
[ __ ] yourself
Sam Tripoli does not like jazz i dude
I'm gonna say this back to sports I
think the Lakers are in trouble this
[ __ ] that LeBron James is doing is the
exact reason they shipped out [ __ ]
Blake Griffin I'm not saying lebra and
Blake some lebrons level but when you
have
at many [ __ ] other things in his town
dude dude would you what we've all
you've sold TV shows when you have a TV
show going do and you're pitching he has
like two plus movies that consumes your
[ __ ] time yeah some of this I said to
be worked out before he left Cleveland
right like come on you don't get all
this stuff done and no it's been I was
even dude it's like but he's gotta have
known he was coming to LA for a while
give him come I'll give him kudos for
that school that he put together though
Akron laughs dude the students get
everything and the parents get [ __ ]
training it was all it was on ESPN that
they dude it was like the day of the
Hall of Fame
well it's also slow time of sports but
ESPN just loves sucking any desiccant
there's a dick anywhere near ESPN it
just shows it is about more [ __ ] [ __ ]
ESPN I just can't take it sucks
yes PN sucks and this whole thing with
like people getting mad because I gonna
really hurt the UFC and the UFC already
is going down oh yeah my opinion is they
dance with the devil signing with ESPN
these guys can't stop smacking their
checks dude that's all it's gonna be you
see fighter smack [ __ ] they're gonna get
rid of all these fighters I could get
Greg Hardy dude Fox was perfect for them
not the Fox News going away but Fox News
doesn't like do this slam Rick Hardy has
hit more women than Ronda Rousey yeah
good point
come on dude bear with me folks these
are the jokes these are the jokes
um look I mean dude it's just unbearable
like this whole thing about oh my god
they cover next name from a rap song on
[ __ ] John men the guy hasn't played
in two years you know why let me say
this I'll tell you why they did that and
I know it looks bad and I'll just say in
their defense he wasn't in the NFL yeah
and they thought they were gonna have to
pay him licensing fees
yeah and they didn't take it out because
of this conspiracy thing and I know
Nancy Johnson is gonna go nuts about
this but this really is the truth they
thought because he wasn't in the NFL he
wasn't part of the Players Association
right I know like hey we have to take
his name out because otherwise we're
gonna have to give him royalties yeah
dad
really all that really whiny NFL he's
not playing this year he's not gonna
play again I don't think he'll ever play
it's never gonna play again I don't know
those did not the play again not because
he can't and not because he doesn't he's
Jose that I think this lawsuit and
everything needs doing and I do think he
was blacklisted and I do think that were
said well I do think they'll be able to
prove that and I do think there's going
to be a settlement for this yeah but I
don't I think that he doesn't want to
you know it's like eventually you just
like I don't want to work for you I
don't want to work for you but I don't
want my money I don't want to be
compensated but well that's you have my
life the damage has been done the damage
has been done and I don't want to play
with your [ __ ] shitty organization you
guys think there's gonna be in the news
all season again absolutely than it is
do you know who wants it the owners the
owners make money in [ __ ] oil and
hedge funds tech ah
they run giant corporations that are
getting more and more deregulation more
more tax breaks more more shipping jobs
out of the country
only a little less [ __ ] [ __ ] up until
the looshing this and if I didn't have
to pay taxes until the last two years if
they're pushing this dude they are they
make dude the NFL their teams are their
side [ __ ] they make this side money on
that [ __ ] dude the real moneys in other
shady ass [ __ ] why are they pushing the
Kaepernick thing man what can you
explain that to me what you're saying
they're pushing the Kaepernick story
keeping it in the headlines this year
fighting with each other it's nobody's
paying attention all the [ __ ] going
on more deregulation of banks more
deregulation of this more [ __ ]
bombing every NFL once once the kappa
thing to go away and the kneeling
because our [ __ ] they see that the
NFL most these guys are 80 they're just
trying to make every [ __ ] ah they're
trying to make every dollar they [ __ ]
can one thing we know for sure they kept
this helmet rule is going to ruin the
NFL it's gonna get even worse well I
tell you what and I wouldn't mind
talking about that because we did have
the Hall of Fame game which is in my
opinion the most boring
meaningless of all preseason games of
all sports you know what it is to every
goddamn priest it's like the fat chick
you see when you just got out of jail
for 30 years you're like look at that
yes so [ __ ] sexy let me hit that
[ __ ] beauty cuz you just wants a game
so badly eight the gate opens it does
one girl like you're you're gonna see
more girls in about ten minutes you're
like oh my god is that the real Nell
Carter give it ten minutes there's like
a bunch of girls we're right around the
corner but they her it is like that yes
I like that it's the most boring and
meaningless game of all the preseason
games and we got a little taste of the
taste of what the helmet rule is gonna
look like a little taste five or six
calls five or six calls a 15-yard it's a
game-changing call it's ridiculous and
it's gonna add 30 minutes to the game
I think they'll learn how to not get
penalized though right well I almost
have to make that reviewable no because
it's such a fast phone the game if they
make you that rule here's what's gonna
happen
many years ago and two years ago or two
or three years ago Vienna there was a
game there was a rule in the NBA that
they tried in pre-season which was if
you if you touch the ball after goes
through the hoop you get electricity
it's a delay of game and they were
calling it all Tigers people would smash
they grabbed the ball made handed they'd
be like penalty and they're like I've
just given you the body like you can't
touch it they stopped calling that
during the season because it was just
like it was just too much so if this
gets to the point that it's just
unbearable the they'll just let this is
another have you guys been following
this this guy real Quan Smith was
holding out because yeah they're the
owners now bears are the the general
managers they're trying to put in the
contracts that they get suspended under
these new rules they don't have to pay
them for the games are suspended and the
players obviously are like yeah it's
stupid these owners are gonna run the
thing integral because the lawyers the
lawyers gonna ruin this game yeah I'm
sorry what is the rule the rule is how
they roll
yes I was gonna ask if I knew that they
been talking about this the whole time
while I've been zoning if you if you if
I used to be you can't launch and you
still can't launch with your head but if
I initiate contact with any part of you
whatsoever with my helmet it is a
15-yard penalty and automatic first down
yeah because people like almost would
weaponize their helmets and I get that
but and they're saying is protecting
both players for the person doing it in
essence it's also problematic for the
guys at the line who automatically come
up and they're right in each other's
faces you know this is more just like
point of contact tackle but no but those
are gonna be foul sue though they're so
they'll rarely call that coming at the
line because uh no rarely call that this
is always going to be catch you know
whoever has the ball and because even if
you're running back I can't like truck
you I can't like lean in and rock and
ride hit you with my helmet and run you
over
that's also a 15-yarder it's going but
going the other way it's what they call
many a lot during that process it's just
getting super excited and then
eventually they're gonna see there's
gonna be giant pushback and I mean dude
they're gonna have a [ __ ] strike and
these players are gonna [ __ ] you know
what are you watching dude just ignore
that it's the no I will not show you
their rule like they're gonna strike and
they're gonna have to [ __ ] try to get
all these rules thrown out well all it
really is is this for the last three or
four years there's been no these players
with CTE s and pretty much [ __ ] Lou
Gehrig's disease and all these different
head traumas that are been from 20 years
ago like people that were players when
we were kids are now killing themselves
and they can't see and you know [ __ ]
Jim McMahon has to wear sunglasses and
can't remember anything and and they're
like hey we got to do something to
protect these people's heads so now
they're coming up with all these new
take off the helmet to make it look like
they care yeah and I kind of agree with
the take off the helmets thing but then
somebody dies you know oh
[ __ ] rugby dude Australian football
you're right it's violent how many look
how many deaths can you look up deaths
from Australian football look up crunch
shows numbers dawg
crunch shows [ __ ] numbers I mean I
don't think removing the helmets is the
answer I do it's a different sport
yes yes it's an unfilled death there's
your list okay when was the last one
1971 yeah some of these my car accidents
yeah that's just a list of everybody
that died in Australia that's every
death in Australia Johnny how many of
those are can go put on Dinka how many
how many babies were eaten by dingoes
okay no offence I saw a baby bear get
hit by a bus the other day in life you
thought real action in Monrovia where my
family lives there's lots of bears it
was worse story my wife my family is
like what do you mean this is the worst
news I thought it was like a big German
shoe I hear it why are you ruining this
weights oh my god no wonder your babies
[ __ ] I don't know if it's okay cuz when
I passed it he was moving his head but
nothing else and I was like oh my god
just let the bear sit there no no no
that like the animal Patrol was already
there because like the bear was in the
neighborhood so they were already
monitoring it where's the mama bear wow
it's gonna be pissed you want that job
like just straight up I contact with me
the whole time
like yeah man I kill a lot of animals
break their legs they can't be fixed why
why you just make a giant Aircast
yeah well they say they'll kick it they
kick it and then just shadows are like
there's so much force on the leg of a
horse like when they swing it all right
Debbie Downer no the way to get to all
of you talk about
I beat a dolphin to death with a shoe I
was underwater you see mag the mag oh
yeah I don't want to see that it looks
Gary [ __ ] right do I'm afraid of those
come on pitch the show to Shark Week
called [ __ ] your pants and it's like we
show somebody shark for the first time
we just watch them [ __ ] their pants and
that's do you that's it you know I would
watch that show
I saw a shirt the other day the [ __ ] out
of me I saw a shark the other day I was
getting in an elevator and there's a
[ __ ] shark in the elevator
no he was just flopping around I was
like oh I'll wait for the next one okay
my over driver last night was telling me
my baby bear bought a bunch of red bonds
I'm like okay and he's like yeah I've
been to next morning I took a red [ __ ]
and it was just yeah my uber driver
you're eating plastic
I gave it's literally the worst I rated
him like red science cut woody are you
serious are you [ __ ] serious hey
maybe that's why him his wife can't get
pregnant right in that [ __ ] plastic
and doing anal okay this girl can't stop
eating Twizzlers and she can't stop
[ __ ] baby
hey so also we got the what else do we
got we got what are we thinking about
football Oscar Mayer tweet that we're
gonna take calls I think there's a
little bit of a I think there's a little
bit of the Twitter tattletale thing
going on here with this I think a little
bit and this what I was saying to you
last night about this it comes down this
shady McCoy thing now what happened with
that I thought she's she's full [ __ ] no
no here's what this is the lay of the
land on the shady McCoy thing and then
you guys can make up your mind about it
he his his lady is squatting in his
house he can't kick her out because of
legalities and like he has to get a
sheriff to come by like a victor and all
this so he legally can't kick her out he
was loaned by a jewelry place a bunch of
expensive jewelry for an event right
that unless I give it back to them I am
on the hook for like eighty thousand
dollars worth
so he says to her we'll figure out this
house situation but I need that jewelry
back cuz I got to return it otherwise
they're gonna charge me 80 grand and
she's like [ __ ] you n-word that's a
that's a gift that's a gift that's mine
I'm keeping the jewelry whatever oh well
they get into a fight a lot think you
know fight about it
here's where perhaps on the thing he did
or didn't it might be a giant
coincidence that the guy that broke into
her house and beat the [ __ ] out of her
only stole those four pieces of jewelry
that's why it looks guilty as [ __ ] so if
I'm shady I go hey listen beat her up
don't beat her up whatever I need these
jewelry's back beat her up don't beat
her all that's on you about don't beat
her up and get my [ __ ] jewels but
also grab a VCR grab a couple forks
don't just only steal this thing because
there's a text-messaging proof that I
was looking for these jewelry back right
the problem is is that women and men
haven't done it yet and maybe some
half-hour weaponizing breakups they're
weaponizing a breakup where it's like
look if I'm a gold digger and I'm
[ __ ] trying to kick it with this
celebrity NBA player basketball player
rap whatever are we getting Blake
Griffin and an aunt oh yeah let's do
that
and if if let's say you're leaving me
you're gonna leave me I'm like I know
it's a contract here if you leave me I'm
gonna [ __ ] go right to because I know
all the trigger words to say that you've
done this that this this this and people
believe it now without there's no trial
right there's no trial anymore it's just
oh you're assumed automatically guilty
and that's what I mean
weaponizing breakups is what people are
doing hardly Twitter do everything
Hardwick is a great example of that
now Hardwick was even worse because he
was broken up with her for years and she
brought this out because she had a movie
coming out yeah and I hope the only
movie she can book after this is donkey
shows in Tijuana
good action did you give him the show
back though I was really good for them
good for them I don't know if I did
still think he's out of there I was my
reason go back to Nerdist [ __ ] Nerdist
man
I mean Nerdist I hope they take a royal
[ __ ] you did say something shady McCoy
it's just like you can say [ __ ] Nerdist
cuz you know ATC for life you can see
for life that's right
I you know dude it's just like these
chicks they get this chance to [ __ ]
win the lottery and when it doesn't work
out they want to scorch the [ __ ]
earth and you know you you know you want
to find out who runs society the rules
Society look at gold diggers the fact
that it's okay to get pregnant by a pro
athlete to try to get child support it's
okay the [ __ ] squat and it [ __ ] be
like no I'm keeping this jewelry do
women run society it's totally is this
is just a way to [ __ ] make money the
fact that you can try to get pregnant
and also a child support for [ __ ] 18
years is un-fuckin'-believable to me
also good like goods like standards like
getting knocked up by broke dicks like
like I get him get a ham sandwich on
this good like good like you know house
I believe should be running things
there's like really good honest like
single dads like Jeff dannis for example
like I was a pro athlete I'd be the
first power gay and I would just be
banging twinks until I'm done playing
and then that would bang [ __ ] hot
chicks after that so they'll give none
of my mind can't get anybody pregnant
you see what I'm saying I would just go
[ __ ] Bane Rodgers I'm just like the
fattest ugliest chick that just is
grateful that I'm even oh oh you know oh
you don't think she'd want money nude
freeze your semen get your get snip snip
go to town dude Derek Jeter it yeah
absolutely give everybody yeah I go the
other way I give everybody AIDS
that's illegal what's that not in
California anymore you you can't get
charged if you give somebody a yeah Wow
well that's a weird reaction that
sounded like when you talk to Mike
you're like oh wow maybe I might get
about getting the AIDS change update the
tenure process let's go
thing you're gonna spread it let's go
let's see Blake Bryant and how [ __ ] he
is man like I mean wait what is $300,000
a month a month a month $300,000 a month
in child support yeah like three Nishiki
kids by him
Oh two more than that that makes sense
$150,000 a child a month that makes a
lot that's just her tipping money from
that like all the stuff we could get
with that like what are you doing dude
my mom my mom raised two kids and
probably made up to $300,000 over like
10 year period I mean and raised two
kids that turned out totally normal
one day the other one my sister's fine
you know says no Blake Griffin is not
paying $258,000 what that's what this
headlines ah I haven't heard him dispute
it and I already need several different
reliable sources
well this is Yahoo like dude Max 35 mil
a year so he loses like why am I doing
this show for free
Britt is paying 32 no she's paying he's
paying way more detailed Susie's paying
thirty two thousand dollars per month
which is a lot better than that's old so
much that's what people make in a year
like 30 mm yeah it's more reasonable to
me that's a car a month yeah but that
dude and she does listen the whole thing
that they do that or they go or she what
would be this kid's lifestyle if they
live with them so 32,000 dollars a month
sounds like a lot to us but there isn't
when you think he's making 35 mil that's
what the route even ever sponsors
doesn't that have to keep going though
like it's not based on his income like
in the future it's based on his income
when they were together right so when
he's five years down right he's gonna
die you get [ __ ] man let's say you met
your you're on a TV show in Canada
you're making fat money and then you get
a kid and the bottom drops out you still
have them no it's because women won't
make the rules of society that's how it
is men just like yeah whatever
just give me a beer I want your beer
whatever rule you want passed that law
that you get 75% of everything I make
for the rest of my life okay [ __ ]
whatever just lend me a beer I want to
go to sleep
i watch SportsCenter and hear fat chicks
talk about LeBron James okay here you
know it's just like guys just don't give
a [ __ ] anymore and then you got these
guys who start like these like men's
rights movements everyone's like lose
and hers you [ __ ] creepers you know
they just they like guys guys deserve
more respect everyone's like even the
guys like shut up and get me a beer you
know it's just it's just weird
so 32000 seems more reasonable to me I
mean I don't want to sound sexist and I
hear everything that you're saying but
if we can get back to the day where we
could slap women I would so much for
ever run for mayor that soundbites gonna
haunt you yeah like I want to run for
mayor
you know what I'll run for mayor and out
my first proposal is bring back slapping
women that's my campaign promise Julia
should we take calls and comments why
not I tweeted right now we got one now
let's ticket we got a call hi you're on
whip pop bud Birds yeah would pop out
you're on the air hello hello stop
running the faucet hello hey [ __ ]
good to be back it's so good to be back
no dude no it's bad back no he's not
coming back killer impression
opportunity in life yeah no II quit what
do you is are you having a stroke right
now and I'm talking to you and him
what do you [ __ ] talking about today
why don't okay somebody's drunk boy it's
like oh let's recap the whole show
is not listening someone just saw a
number up hey hey let's run down what
we've been talking about what are you
talking about hey you guys you guys
think the Lakers make the playoffs
I do but barely yeah I don't think this
is gonna go well I think the Lakers
[ __ ] up
by not trying to do whatever it takes
again what sucks is that why Leonard we
have to talk about the Lakers for the
next four years every day of my [ __ ]
life
it's not even and football and baseball
and everything happening
UFC just happened and still all night
last night at the Comedy Store
I'm hanging out with my good friend Nate
Diaz [ __ ] Lake or lake or Lakers
Lakers Lakers I'm like it's not a
basketball season give me give me a
[ __ ] one-month breather well I don't
have to talk about the [ __ ] Lakers
one month we had a lucky 15 months where
it wasn't we didn't have to hear about
the Lakers being great all the time guys
call in and talk about the Lakers with
Jason please go if you call it talk
about the Lakers three sir hanging up on
you three two three two eight two seven
four two four if you say the l-word by
FISH Lisa he get a stroke fish Lisa yeah
buy fish Lisa
how could you did that turn by the way
the Clippers were kind of entertaining
there for what five years yeah did you
see that you know he's never the Hornets
they suck a dick did your owners shop
okay sure cuz you brought it up
the Hornets suck we is there any way I
named my Michael Jordan guess who's
gonna be good us you guys sucked by the
way you know who I hate Aaron you want
some bass I'm taking a stab at every
walk day Dave Roberts man that guy not
just might not make the postseason
they are he's don't think about that
he's been given everything he's been
given everything yeah he's been given
everything and he's just wants to be
like him Andrew fever like I'm so smart
oh oh my body got supply I'm like do
baseball's about rhythm man you can't
get in a rhythm when you don't know if
you're playing or not okay
Kiki you're gonna play first base I've
never played for a special play first
base
you know and then he goes and plays for
space it's like it's funny that a guy
who manages who didn't play regularly
might have that opinion oh dude
whoa I just took a shot at they are some
you heard [ __ ] you heard here you say
like he's just trying to it's like when
a clean comic who sucks wants to build a
comedy club that the only does clean
comedy and then it ends up sucking
because like they just wanted to create
a place for their comedy to shine are
you saying Dave Roberts is like that
he's creating a place where young Dave
Roberts could have played more maybe
whoa that's some deep shot just might
not make the post season
yeah dude with that line up and that
payroll first shame for shame but they
got rid of that joke Lauren Logan
Forsythe so that's great
do I like the guys they got it's just
like you've got dude dude stop playing
Muncie stop acting like Muncey's this
guy who's kind of play every day
he's not healing dude let him come off
the bench there's God dude
I've never seen a baseball team in my
[ __ ] life they're [ __ ] you can't
tell me who the starters are who the
starters
yeah there's two guys who start every
time and they're the two new dudes
everybody else is like rotated in and
out it's like we don't need that no
bones you're at first [ __ ] the new
dude dozer a second Machado a third
Turner when he can play if breaking news
what I'll be at the belly room Saturday
at 10:30 I was on an epic baseball yeah
just got a pretty loud start breaking it
up I tried why don't they put Taylor
back out and center Machado at Short
good time I'm with you dude well if you
want to keep Machado you better put his
assets yeah he's like I agree with well
dude real quick he's not hitting well
he's not hitting well at all I mean like
we're we're going through it but you
can't get in a rhythm they're telling us
we got murderers row look at our batting
average dude there's like no guy batting
300 in any of the Dodgers any Matt catch
the closest rising yeah any scum [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the bed
whatever it is he sobbed 300 now he was
like 295 lesson I mean that's like
before you took him to cow dude it's
like dude let people play let him
into rhythm when a dude who these guys
go for 21 [ __ ] runs the next day
three of the guys who had two home runs
aren't even [ __ ] playing what are you
doing that's mike matheny [ __ ] right
there yeah that's [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] man
it's like [ __ ] dude there's rhythm I get
that you do in games analytics it's
ruining the Dodgers you ruined the
[ __ ] World Series by putting a giant
Asian in that got shelled in Houston
it's that going what else Woods who had
another great game against Houston
Alex Woods can pitch against Houston
it's [ __ ] ridiculous diamond I can't
stand that Muncey's I'm first
it makes no [ __ ] sense it just makes
no sense it just makes no Bellinger
should be there
Turner should be up there okay it just
makes some sense I mean Jim's not a
starter anywhere Kemp hasn't been
playing well let him sit we wasn't even
supposed to make the team why did we act
like we owe him something he got him one
more all-star game he could [ __ ] feel
good about himself
yeah send them back to [ __ ] Atlanta
give us Co Burson back you don't want
him back believe me what the guy sucks
Kover see yeah you told me he was great
man vs. crazy been mediocre I can see
why he's a rotation player best best
hitter in baseball right now who is Matt
Carpenter oh that's true yeah carpenter
mmm
breaking carpenter crack carpenter
Cardinals hey that's Matt card
guess who hits me up all the time now
smack card she's alive yeah I don't know
man where does she hit you yeah yeah I
like how you like I'm not gonna talk to
her every day like one of my photos
about a month ago yeah she likes me why
have her hit it have her hit us up he's
almost got 30 homers huh Wow yeah
Dodgers [ __ ] dudes Dave Roberts he was
adding 140 in May yeah he was in such a
to 82 yeah well that's what it's called
that what Menten michael jackson called
- Jesus - that's what happens when a
manager lets you play through your ass
yeah yeah yeah
well when the the Cardinal sucks so
everybody gets to play you know I you
know I'm really not liking the dogs
utility players pitching I think it
makes baseball look bad
you know it'd be even cooler fan from
the stand fan from the state dude you're
talking about that 16 inning game he
gave up dude Roberts gave up he had Rich
Hill warming up to come in and instead
of you know said he just gave up when he
brought [ __ ] Hernandez in let him pitch
and it was like home run therapy
immediately vanderway events wave the
white flag did you guys he or even care
about Terrell Owens his separate Hall of
Fame thing first of all the fact that
Ray Lewis is like someone put out all
the stats and at the bomb was two
murders no like dude just babbling like
did he quote OJ Simpson and his [ __ ]
thing daddy like someone said he like he
was just rambling you know I said well
he he guaranteed that his speech would
be a minimum of 20 minutes which is
already like good god and any black
comic granite Eddie oh did he ever
he didn't even stand at the podium he
was walking back and forth like Dane
Cook looked like Leslie Jones when
Leslie I bring up to do River Lord know
they're gonna be the worst sport sports
related event to attend right any kind
of hall-of-famer
no no dude I mean it's full of everybody
who loves these guys so it's got to be
fun see your friend like if you're if
Tebow is getting an award it would be
hilarious to see him up there just
[ __ ] man-to-man
no not like your friends are up there
hold on let's say let's say what's your
favorite team but yeah that's a key know
what is let's say to us you're Julius
Peppers Sheila Scott could the guys that
he's mildly [ __ ] let's say you're
all gonna get a Hall of Fame right who's
your all-time favorite let's say an NFL
player yeah Steve Smith Oh that'd be
great Steve Smith well I'd still have no
interest in sitting there for 30 minutes
watching him ice up ice up he just
talked about icing up no cuz they all
try to get serious and talk about their
family growing I have no injury if I
could god the only Hall of Fame I wanted
to go to
um Patrick Ewing's I just couldn't make
it I was gonna go to that to see him get
in the Hall of Fame I would listen to
him talk because I'm like the whole time
be like duty he's got Jamaican accent
MBA whereas I think it's the they don't
call the NBA Hall of Fame right it's the
professional basketball yeah your shirt
right there makes it looks like it's
like you broke out of a gay prison in
[ __ ] 1930s I did well it was a
forty-three spring Springfield you know
how I you know I broke out oh I tied a
bunch of condoms together and climbed
out the window
used of course I'm kidding we didn't use
condoms in prison you know what's crazy
about Ray Lewis of speech is he ended it
with by FISH Leisha coming in strong by
fish you know I say that because I tried
to go by Felicia in emojis but I saw
just a hand and then fish and then Lisa
got it why is there a whatsit there's an
emoji for a Lisa no I just type in the
story just crashes and burning five fish
Lisa we're gonna call you yes I
guarantee your omelette punch-drunk
all right hi the Danish ghost Casper the
Danish girl hi Casper are you a big fan
yeah fan of Morten Andersen are you a
fan of Morten Andersen that fellow Dane
of course I am of course I am
why do you sell automated hi I am a
ghost
how are you I'm watching the live feed
on on YouTube and I delete I guess so
funny is he falling for five hours
he's been tweeting us like he tweets a
bit like I feel like I know this guy
yeah he's always tweet us never thought
he had this accent right I love of
course he does you know it's so like
never in a million years it's like pets
cues got your make an accent I like I
didn't know he was Jamaican no it's a
late last year honestly and no idea and
he was a coach of Hornets Yeah right
Casper what's up what are you up to bias
for talk to us are we rooted for your
[ __ ] country during the World Cup
yeah we we lost a lot of money
I know we should have won that game we
should have won that game against
Croatia I don't know what happened it
was yeah
I'm not over it I'm just beating your
women still is there a lot of domestic
violence no no no we're not we're not
there's not because they have you seen
their women they beat them do the
fantasy draft podcast for patreon again
oh we will for sure we have we're gonna
talk about that today we're kind of all
a man glad you called it the funniest
thing what everybody loved was that from
the first pic you're like [ __ ] [ __ ]
there's nobody left God every [ __ ] pic
trip was like god dammit
see that we never should have done this
not as only 31 quarterbacks left there's
only 31 quarterbacks left now [ __ ]
Johnny about I love Dana
so Oh Dana oh yeah so is that Jewish
football big out there do people care is
there only you know uh well well soccer
and Denmark is really really good right
that's our net of course but American
football American football is also its
gaining the last like 10 15 years it's
been growing a lot I miss NFL Europe I
think we're like us yeah and fail Europe
was great I don't know why they got rid
of it what time of the date is it are
they our games on there in NFL games the
first the early game is at 7 p.m.
that's the first one oh wow that's great
and then too late no that sucks man I
gotta go to [ __ ] work so the late
game is like 2:30 a.m. it starts 2:30
a.m. is yeah Wow
yeah it sucks so yeah you must have to
record them and then listen to them
later or something now you brought up an
interesting point which I'll try to do I
can't promise anything because I know
how busy this guy is but Theo von is a
big fantasy guy he's been playing for
three years now and and Kasper brought
up a point he messaged me
on Twitter and he goes please do the
draft again and make sure have Sam on
the draft podcast but can you also get
Theo on that podcast as well and have
him be in the league yeah let's keep
saying hey who's in our league it would
be we have to decide well Ari won't do
funny his comments and his thoughts hey
man so Theo draft is like a man I'm
getting Cam Newton on my team man I
don't Lee he's got an untrustworthy face
got strategies like nobody would yeah we
got well usually what we do is like
throw out the times usually half of the
league is comics and people on the show
and then half of the league is fans so
and guess what we just guarantee Casper
you got a spot in them and I think
Johnny I'll put Casper a guy that
tattooed himself last year he's gonna
let him back in another tack point [ __ ]
boy for life yeah yeah Matt Devlin's
gotta get another tattoo yeah we got to
get him back in but he's got to get
double just just the word double like
he's got to get a family portrait of
punch from sports on yes
what that's how you do it today
call hour of the day caller of we gotta
get back to the award show I love that
guy by the way yeah very cool guy I
think he had that accent I followed him
at all I am yeah I kind of get what
you're saying though like you win he's
Daisy I'll talk to him he's danish what
do you think he's gonna sound like hey
y'all oh yes sorry it was cousin Jeb for
a second hey who's on lines
you're on with punching sport what's up
guys it's Stephen from Dallas hi what do
you all think about the corner khabib
matchup in the future and what are your
thoughts on the DC Brock fight if
that'll actually happen if you thought
it will bow down for that or they end up
paying
what are y'all up on that well we talked
about it a bit earlier in the show but I
mean I I don't give a [ __ ] about the
Brock thing I think it's disrespectful
to keep a Miocic butt and then you know
the Connor and khabib thing like we were
saying earlier I hope it happens I hope
nobody gets hurt we've actually prayed
to the gods bet dsi calm to make sure
that happens use coupons 25 and but will
seem in I mean I I give a [ __ ] about the
Brock thing I don't give a [ __ ] about
Brock I don't I think yeah I would say
the same for a lot of people I would say
the same for a lot of people there I've
heard that it's gonna be a lot of money
on the us these parts be able to get him
to fight so I know I know that the big
draw but like you said they Connor could
be there's going to be way bigger and
way more anticipated I think everybody
is extremely ready for that I'm very
excited for that I only think about is I
really wanted it to be a Moscow there
was all the talk it was going to be a
Moscow yeah and it would have been like
Raqqa for all over again you start off
with that one yeah that'll be in Vegas
and then the Diaz Nate Diaz fight
Poirier fights in New York that's right
also that Diaz fine I forgot to bring
that up be a fantastic one as well
I know I'll always refer dear did hey
dude I'm trying to get some shows out in
Dallas so if I come out you got to come
and hang out Thank You dude I appreciate
it man who's your what's your football
team I there we go lissa I didn't think
it could get worse but Felicia Lissa
this is guys it's good to be back
daddy's back and it was fun
we talked sports we laughed we cried we
questioned fighting andis mothering
skills it was a full [ __ ] day your
mother mother around the horn final I'm
excited for football to be coming around
the corner next episode we'll talk about
we'll talk about on the patreon so
please
everybody subscribed to patreon we got a
lot of cool things going on there the
next one we'll talk a little bit more
specifically about our fantasy league
and there will be people coming out in
our fantasy leagues actually difficulty
from being patreon subscribers actually
one way to get in
subscribe to patreon and suck it all
right man Johnny any thoughts no fight
nany
alright Sam good that by Aaron
baseball's bye guys